ah Kevin Smith how we loved you I
apologize in advance for the bitter
review that you're about to watch kinda
a couple of dicks because that's the
original title and I like it better than
cop-out
okay so cop-out is a buddy cop comedy
directed by Kevin Smith in which Bruce
Willis plays old school white cop and
Tracy Morgan plays not Eddie Murphy so I
understand that cop out supposed to be
some throwback to the 80s cop movies
with this synthesized soundtrack that
sounds like Beverly Hills Cop but it
just comes across as a poorly executed
buddy cop comedy - the comedy it's like
a second-rate Starsky and Hutch now I'm
a longtime Kevin Smith fan I generally
like his stuff but by ten minutes in the
cop out you can just tell what you paid
for horrible pacing force jokes and one
annoying ass Tracy Morgan I mean the
pacing of this movie was just all over
the place I mean no cop-outs not
supposed to be taken too seriously but
you gotta have good pacing otherwise the
movie just feels like cop-out you know
that kind of pacing works like this
movie was either written by someone with
no attention span or an Alzheimer's
patient pick one I mean it had Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull pacing if that
means anything
the characters were so annoying in this
movie I kid you not Tracy Morgan is
literally the most annoying and needy
human being I've ever seen in the movie
whatsoever only rivaled by Sean William
Scott in this movie I mean I could watch
Paris Hilton describe the political
problems that plague society in this day
and age and what she would do to help
the problem and not be as annoyed as
watching Tracy Morgan and Sean William
Scott and cop-out I mean usually if you
put two people like that on screen
together it could make for some
sweet-ass moments in which they're
trying to one-up and upstage each other
I swear to God when you're watching it
you just feel like he should do
something heroic like pull the theater
fire alarm just to spare everybody
the only reason Sean William Scott
didn't annoy me as much as Tracy Morgan
is because you only have to put up with
him for two scenes in the movie I kid
you not people two scenes in the movie
the guys in two scenes only I mean I saw
the guy on the cop out standing in the
movie theater and he's only in two
scenes in the movie I shouldn't complain
because I'm glad he was only in two
scenes in the movie but that being said
having him on the stand II for the movie
is like having Aunt Beru rocking her
glass of blue milk on the cover of Star
Wars most if not
absolutely all the funny scenes in the
movie we're in the red band trailer so I
put the link for the red band trailer in
the sidebar go check it out save
yourself some cash what did I like about
the movie it was good to see Kevin Smith
make another movie that was cool
and it ended I mean I had a couple of
funny moments in the movie but nothing
that really made me just lol I mean in a
comedy you just gotta have a big lol and
oMG so I mean there are two kinds of
people who are going to watch this movie
Kevin Smith fans who are going to be
disappointed in cop out as a Kevin Smith
movie or everyone else we're going to
see cop out is just some great be buddy
cop comedy that makes Showtime look like
freaking draining day what does it not
fail at it does not fail at being what
it really is the untitled sequel to cop
and a half this should have just called
at that cop and a half 20 years later so
in the kind of world where something has
to come last I'm gonna go ahead and say
that unquestionably this is Kevin
Smith's worst movie just go ahead and
save your money and your time on this
one but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to do something free
then click on the link in the sidebar to
see more and subscribe
Oh